NOW BACK TO THE SHOW.
>> HELLO.
WE ARE BACK.
LOTS OF NEWS WENT ON WHILE WE
WERE APART.
PETE DAVIDSON AND KIM KARDASHIA
ARE STILL TOGETHER.
IT'S A COUPLE THAT MAKES ME ASK
WOULD WORLD WAR III BE SUCH A
BAD THING?
BUT WE'VE BEEN OFF FOR A FEW
WEEKS AND FOR GOOD REASON.
THIS IS A NEWS CHANNEL, AND WAR
IS NEWS FREIGHT ACTUALLY IT'S
BREAKING NEWS AND IT'S BREAKING
ALL THE TIME.
YOU CAN'T SPELL BREAKING NEWS
WITHOUT A BREAK.
SOMETIMES WE DO NEED A BREAK.
FIRST, LET'S ASSESS WHAT WE KNOW
.
>> SO, UKRAINE IS A COUNTRY IN
EUROPE.
IT EXISTS TO ANOTHER COUNTRY
CALLED RUSSIA.
RUSSIA IS A BIGGER COUNTRY,
RUSSIA IS A POWERFUL COUNTRY.
RUSSIA DECIDED TO INVADE A
SMALLER COUNTRY CALLED UKRAINE.
BASICALLY THAT'S WRONG.
>> I LOVE HOW SHE SPEAKS TO ME.
LIKE I HAVE A HEAD INJURY.
ABA DO.
IT'S TRUE RUSSIA INVADED UKRAIN
AND LIKE JOE BIDEN READING
CHILDREN'S BOOK, WITH EVERY
PASSING DAY, THINGS JUST GET
MORE DESPERATE, MEANWHILE, MY
MOTHER-IN-LAW ESCAPE FROM
UKRAINE TO POLAND, NO SHE DIDN'
WRITE OUT ON HER BROOM, SHE GOT
OUT WITH THE HELP OF SOME VERY
AMAZING PEOPLE WHICH I WILL GET
INTO IN THE SECOND.
KNOW MY WIFE IS OUT THERE IN
WARSAW TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY FOR HER MOM TO GET HOME.
WHICH MEANS I'M ALL ALONE.
BUT I'VE BEEN TRYING TO KEEP
BUSY.
IT'S BEEN REALLY TOUGH.
BUT I'VE MANAGED TO MAKE SOME
SYMPATHETIC FRIENDS.
LOOK, I HAD TO DO SOMETHING.
CHANGING ALL THE LOCKS AND THE
DOORS OF THE APARTMENT ONLY TOO
ABOUT AN HOUR.
IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, THANKS TO
FOX I WAS ABLE TO GET MY
MOTHER-IN-LAW OUT OF KYIV.
ITS AMAZING TALE THEY PICKED HE
UP IN A SMALL VILLAGE AND DROVE
FOUR HOURS, DAYS EVEN AND WAS
ABLE TO GET HER OUT OF DANGER I
POLAND.
I BELIEVE THEY DID THIS SO I
COULD USE MY NEW MOTHER-IN-LAW
JOKES.
FOR EXAMPLE, MY MOTHER-IN-LAW
WAS STUCK IN KYIV AND TWO POSED
A DILEMMA, GET HER OUT A BLOCKE
ON FACEBOOK.
DEAD SILENCE, BUT SERIOUSLY, MY
MUTT WIFE WANTED ME TO SEND
SOMEBODY IN TO GET HER I WOULD,
BUT I HAVE A ONE STAR RATING ON
UBER.
MY MOTHER-IN-LAW WAS STUCK IN
AND TO BE HONEST I'M NOT CRAZY
ABOUT HER, SO AFTER HOURS OF
ARGUING ABOUT IT WE CAME TO AN
AGREEMENT IF RESCUED, AND BACK
IN HER WILL.
BUT ENOUGH.
IN ALL HONESTY SHE MADE AN
INSANE TREK ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND MADE IT OUT ALIVE THANKS TO
A HARDY BAND OF FOX NEWS
EMPLOYEES WHO DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
HER, BUT OFFERED TO HELP HER TO
NEW THEY KNEW HOW TO MAKE
MOLOTOV COCKTAILS OUT OF HAND
SANITIZER AND A BOTTLE OF
PUERILE AND WHO KNEW THAT KAT
COULD DRINK THAT.
I HAVEN'T SEEN MY WIFE THAT
HAPPY SINCE I MOVED INTO THE
GUESTROOM.
BUT I HAVE FOX NEWS SCOTT WILDER
, AND STEVE HARRIGAN AMONG
OTHERS TO THINK FOR THIS.
THOUGH IT'S OBVIOUS, THE WAR IN
UKRAINE IS AN UGLY BLOODIED
THING, IT'S ALSO A WAR BETWEEN
COMPETING NARRATIVES, ALSO
COMPETE TO THIS NEW BLOCK OF WAR
.
IT'S ALWAYS TWO MOVIES ON ONE
SCREEN.
UKRAINE